he says I should have married my
business partner I think you might have
considered it
and so I don't see the marriage has been
easier than business I think that the
the skills that we learn being business
partners just directly translated to
being married our communication as a
couple has gotten so much better so much
faster than I think a lot of people
probably experience because we have the
pressure of the business so we had to
learn to how to in that setting which
then translates over to the personal
study like it just can't not and so the
way that we give feedback the way that
we encourage each other the way that we
deliver news that we don't want to to
each other I mean it's all just kind of
one